let's remind ourselves a little bit of
what we already know about orbitals and
i've gone over this early on in the
regular chemistry playlist but let's say
that this is the nucleus of our atom
super small and around that we have our
first orbital the 1s orbital and the 1s
orbital you can kind of just view it as
a cloud
as a cloud
around the nucleus so you have your 1s
orbital and it can fit 2 electrons so
the first electron will go into the 1s
orbital and then the second electron
that will also go in the 1s orbital so
for example hydrogen has only 1 electron
so it would go into 1s helium has one
more so that will also go in the 1s
orbital after that is filled then you
move on to the 2s orbital
you move on to the 2s
onto the 2s orbital and the 2s orbital
you can view it as a shell around the 1s
orbital and all of these you know you
can't really view it in our conventional
way of thinking you can kind of view it
as a probability cloud of where you
might find the electrons but for
visualization purposes just imagine it's
kind of a shell cloud around around the
1s orbital
so imagine it
as kind of a as a fuzzy shell around the
1s orbital so it's around the 1s orbital
and your next electron will go there
will go there and then the 4th electron
will also go there and i drew these
arrows upward and downward because the
first electron that goes in the 1s
orbital has a has a has one spin and
then the one the next electron to go
into the 1st orbital will have the
opposite spin and so they keep pairing
up in that way they have opposite spins
now if we keep adding electrons now we
move to the two p orbitals
we move to the 2p and there there's
actually you can view it as there are
three
two p orbitals and each of them can hold
two electrons so we can hold hold a
total of six electrons in the two p
orbitals and let me draw them for you
just you can visualize it so if we were
to label our axes here so think in three
dimensions so imagine that that right
there is the x axis
that is our x-axis
let's let me do this in different colors
let's say that this right here is our
y-axis
that is our y-axis and then we have a
z-axis i'll do that in blue
so let's say we have a z axis just like
that
you actually have a p orbital that goes
along each of those axes so you could
have your so let me do it so you have
your two let me do this in a
let me do it in the same colors so you
have your 2
2 p sub x
orbital and so what that'll look like is
a dumbbell shape that's going in the x
direction so let me draw my my best
attempt at drawing this it's a dumbbell
shape
that goes in the x direction in kind of
both directions and it's actually
symmetric i'm drawing this end bigger
than that end so it looks like it's
coming out at you a little bit but let
me draw a little bit better than that
can do a better job
and maybe it comes out like that
i don't get remember these are really
just probability clouds but it it's
helpful to kind of visualize them as
maybe a little bit more things that we
would see in our world but i think
probability cloud's the best way to
think about it so that is the 2px
orbital and then i haven't talked about
how they get filled yet but then you
also have your 2py orbital which will go
in this axis but same idea kind of a
dumbbell shape in the y direction going
in both
along the y-axis
going in that direction and in that
direction then of course so let me do
this 2
p
y
and then you also have your 2pz
you also have your 2 p
z
and that goes in the z direction up like
that
and then
downwards
like that
so when you keep adding electrons the
first so so far we've added four
electrons if you add a fifth electron if
you add a fifth electron you would
expect it to go into
the 2px
the 2px orbital right there so even
though this 2px orbital can fit two
electrons the first one goes there the
very next one won't go into that one it
actually wants to separate itself within
the p orbital so the very next electron
that you add won't go into 2px it'll go
into 2py
and then the one after that won't go
into 2py or 2px it'll go into 2pz they
try to separate themselves
and then if you add another electron if
you add let's see we've added 1 2 3 4 5
6 7. if you had an 8th electron that
will then go into the 2px orbital so the
8th electron would go there but it would
have the opposite spin so this is just a
little bit of review with a little bit
of visualization now given what we just
reviewed let's think about what's
happening with carbon
carbon carbon
has six electrons
six
electrons its electron configuration it
is one s two two electrons in the one s
orbital then 2 s2
then
2 p2 right only has 2 left because it
has a total of 6 electrons 2 go here
then there then 2 are left to fill the p
orbitals so if you go based on what we
just drew and what we just talked about
here what you would expect for carbon
what you'd expect for carbon let me just
draw it out the way i did this so you
have your 1s orbital
your 2s orbital and then you have your 2
p
x orbital your two p y orbital and then
you have your two p z orbital if you
just go straight from the electron
configuration you would expect carbon so
the 1s orbital fills first so that's our
first electron our second electron
our third electron and then we go to our
2s orbital that fills an x third
electron then fourth electron
then you would expect maybe your fifth
electron to go in the 2px we could have
said 2py or 2z just depends on how you
label the axes but you would have your
fifth electron go into one of the p
orbitals and then you would expect your
sixth to go into another
so you would expect that to be kind of
the configuration for carbon and if we
were to draw it
if we were to draw it let me draw our
axes
so that is our y-axis
and then this is our x-axis
that let me draw a little bit better
than that
so that is the x-axis and of course you
have your z-axis you have to think in
three dimensions a little bit
a little squiggly line there so let me
then you have your z-axis
just like that so first we fill the 1s
orbital so if our nucleus is sitting
here our 1s orbital gets filled with 2
electrons you can imagine that as a
little cloud around the nucleus then we
fill
the 2s orbital and that would be a cloud
a cloud around that kind of a shell
around that and then we would put one
electron in the
2px orbital so one electron will start
kind of jumping around or moving around
depending on how you want to think about
it in that orbital over there 2px and
then you'd have the next electron
jumping around or moving around the 2py
orbital so it'd be moving around
like this
and if you went just off of this you'd
say you know what these guys
this guy over here and that guy over
there is lonely he's looking for a
opposite spin partner this would be the
only places that bonds would form you
would expect some type of bonding to
form on the with the x orbitals or the y
orbitals now that's what you would
expect if you just straight up kind of
stayed with this model of how things
feel and how orbitals look
the reality of carbon and i guess the
simplest reality of carbon is if you
look at a at a methane molecule is very
different than what you would expect
here with a methane first of all what
you would expect here is that carbon
would probably maybe it would form two
bonds but we know carbon forms four
bonds that it wants to fill it it wants
to pretend like it has eight electrons
that frankly almost every every atom
wants to pretend like it has eight
electrons so in order for that to happen
you have to think about a different
reality this isn't really what's
happening when carbon bonds
so not
not
what
happens
when
carbon bonds
what's really happening when carbon
bonds
and this will kind of go into the
discussion of sp3 hybridization but what
you're going to see is it's not that
complicated of a topic it sounds very
daunting but it's actually pretty
straightforward what really happens when
carbon bonds because it wants to form
four bonds with things is its
configuration you could imagine looks
more like this
it looks more like this
so you have 1s
and we have 2 electrons there and then
you have your 2s
2px
2py
and 2pz now what you can imagine is it
wants to form 4 bonds it has four
electrons that are willing to pair up
with electrons from other molecules in
the case of methane that other molecule
is a hydrogen so what you can imagine is
is that the electrons actually maybe the
hydrogen takes attracts this brings this
this electron right here into a higher
energy state and puts it into 2z that's
one way to visualize it so this other
guy here maybe ends up over there and
then these two guys are over there and
over there now all of a sudden it looks
like you have four lonely guys and they
are ready to bond and that's actually
more accurate of how carbon bonds it
likes to bond with four other people now
it's a little bit arbitrary which
electron it ends up in each of these
things and even if you had this type of
bonding you would expect
you would expect things to bond along
the x y and z axis the reality is the
reality of carbon is that these these
four electrons in its second shell
don't look like they're in just you know
the first one doesn't look like it's
just in the s orbital and then the p's
and y and z for the other three they all
look like they're a little bit in the s
and a little bit in the p orbitals so
let me let me make that clear so instead
of this being a 2s what it really looks
like for carbon is that this looks like
a 2
sp3 orbital this looks like a 2sp3
orbital that looks like a 2sp3 orbital
that looks like a 2sp3 orbital they all
look like they're kind of in the same
orbital and this special type of you
know it sounds very fancy this sp3
hybridized orbital what it actually
looks like is something that's in
between an s and a p orbital it has a 25
s nature and a 75 p nature you can
imagine it as being a mixture of these
four things that's what that's the
behavior that carbon has so when you mix
them all when you mix them all instead
of having a an s orbital so if this is a
nucleus we do a cross section an s
orbital looks like
that and a p orbital
and a p orbital
looks something like that in cross
section
when you so this is a i mean this is an
s
and that is a p when they get mixed up
the orbital looks like this an sp3
orbital looks something like this
looks something like this
this is an sp
a hybridized sp3 orbital hybrid just
means a combination of two things
hybridized a hybrid car it's a
combination of gas and electric
hybridized orbital it's a combination of
s and p and a hybridized sp3 orbitals
are the orbitals when carbon bonds with
things like hydrogen are really when it
bonds with anything
and so if you looked at a molecule of
methane and you know people talk about
high sp3 hybridized or orbitals all
they're saying
is that you have a carbon in the center
maybe let me draw the oh yeah let's say
that's the carbon nucleus right there
and instead of having one s and three p
orbitals it has four sp3 orbitals
it has four sp3 orbitals so let me try
my best at drawing the four sp3 orbitals
so let's say this is the big lobe that's
kind of pointing near us and it has a
small lobe in the back
and then you have another one that has a
big lobe
like that and a small lobe in the back
and then you have one that's going back
behind the page so let me draw that so
you can kind of imagine a three-legged
stool
and then its small lobe will come out
like that and then you have one where
the big lobe is pointing straight up
the big lobe is pointing straight up and
has a small lobe going down you can
imagine it is kind of a three-legged
a three-legged stool one of them's
behind like that it's pointing straight
up so three-legged stool with something
yeah i guess you know it's kind of like
a tripod i guess is the best way to
think about it and so that's car that's
the carbon nucleus in the center and
then you have the hydrogens so that's
our carbon right there and then you have
your hydrogens
you have a hydrogen here a hydrogen just
has one
electron in the 1s orbital so the
hydrogen is just
has 1s orbital you have a hydrogen here
just has a 1s orbital it has a hydrogen
here 1s orbital hydrogen here 1s orbital
and so this is how the hydrogen orbital
and the carbon orbitals get mixed the
carb the
the hydrogens 1s orbital bonds with well
each of the hydrogens 1s orbital bonds
with each of the carbons sb3 orbitals
and just so you get a little bit more
notation so when people talk about
hybridized sp3 orbitals all they're
saying is look carbon doesn't bond
doesn't bond
when once carbon this right here is a
molecule of methane right this is ch4
ch4
or methane and it doesn't bond like you
would expect if you just went with
straight vanilla s and p orbitals if you
just went straight villa sp orbitals the
bonds would form maybe you know the
hydrogen might be there and there and if
it had four hydrogens you know maybe
there and there or depending on how you
want to think about it but the reality
is it doesn't look like that it looks
more like a tripod it has a tetrahedral
shape
it has a tetrahedral shape
tetrahedral shape
and the best way that that can be
explained if you
i guess the shape of the structure is if
you have four equally
four of the same types of orbital shapes
and those four types of orbital shapes
are hybrids between s's and p's and now
one other
piece of notation to know and sometimes
people think you know it's a very fancy
term but when you have a bond
between two molecules where the orbitals
are kind of pointing at each other so
you can imagine right here the this
hydrogen orbital is pointing in that
direction this sp3 orbital is pointing
that direction they're overlapping right
around
right around here this is called a sigma
bond this is called a sigma
sigma bond we're kind of the overlap is
in is in along the same axis is if you
connected the two molecules over here
you connect the two molecules the
overlap is on that same axis this is the
form the strongest form of covalent
bonds and this will be a good basis for
discussion maybe in the next video when
we talk a little bit about pi bonds but
the big takeaway of this video is just
understand what does it mean what is a
sp3 hybridized orbital nothing fancy
just a combination of s and p orbitals
has 25 s character 75 p character which
makes sense and it's what exists when
carbon forms bonds especially in the
case of methane that's what describes
its tetrahedral tetrahedral structure
that's why we have a bond why we have an
angle between the various branches of
109.5 degrees which some teachers might
want you to know so it's useful to know
if you take this angle right here
109.5 that's the same thing as that
angle or if you were to go behind it
that angle right there 109.5
degrees explained by sp3 hybridization
the bonds themselves are sigma bonds the
overlap is along the axis connecting the
hydrogen and the carbon